now to Ben Affleck who's made his first
TV appearance since completing treatment
for alcoholism last October feeling good
and looking good outside Kimmel studio
then took a ton of selfies with bands
while six-year-old son Samuel stood by
his side
once inside Ben finally put the rumors
to rest he will not play Batman again
maybe temporary I tried to direct a
version of it but just kind of couldn't
come up with a version that couldn't
crack it and so I thought it was like
you know time to let someone else take a
shot at I guess I'm not Batman
speculation of Ben's Batman retirement
has been swirling for a while oh my god
it's like every time I mention Batman it
gets this huge you know we're gonna do
it good we're gonna do it the right way
and the fans are gonna love it
last night he literally retired the cake
with Kimball why does she have a number
12 on it that's that's Brady's number
you can't be a hero unless you're
wearing number 12 Brady as in Tom Brady
this Boston native is a huge Patriots
fan so huge in fact when Samuel started
rooting for his hometown teams in LA
this is how been remodelled his bedroom
that's a chair you sit in that yeah and
is that supposed to be Tom Brady that is
Tom Brady's yeah I don't my acquaintance
is creeping it is Marie P that's what we
do with our show tonight take our
neuroses and we put it on oh you dick
you but time my sons in therapy here to
show
do I have to say anymore it's my
daughter
[Music]